Comment expliquer que des personnes issues
d’un milieu social similaire ont des modes
de vie et des goûts similaires?
Cette question est celle que Pierre Bourdieu
s’est posée dans son célèbre ouvrage,
la distinction. Il y reformule ce qui sera
l’un des concepts central de son œuvre
: l’habitus.
Je m’appelle Sylvain Dramaix. Je suis professeur
de sciences sociales dans le secondaire supérieur
et je vous expose dans cette vidéo, l’essentiel
du chapitre 3 de la distinction de Pierre
Bourdieu : l’habitus et l’espace des styles
de vie.
Dans l’épisode précédent, je vous expliquais
que les agents c’est-à-dire les individus,
ont une position sociale déterminée par
la détention d’un volume de différents
capitaux : économique, culturel, social et
symbolique. L’espace social est stratifié
en 3 grandes classes : dominante, moyenne
et populaire, elles-mêmes subdivisées en
fractions dominantes et dominées selon la
structure des capitaux détenus. Si cela n’est
pas clair pour vous, je vous renvoie vers
cette vidéo qui vous donnera les bases pour
comprendre le propos du jour.
A cet espace des positions sociales qui peut
évoluer dans le temps, faut-il le rappeler,
correspond un espace des styles de vie. Pour
un ensemble d’individus situés au même
endroit de l’espace social, correspond un
ensemble cohérent de pratiques et de comportements
qui constituent un style de vie objectivable.
Bourdieu insiste sur le fait que ce sont non
seulement des attitudes mais aussi un rapport
au monde qui est lié à chaque position dans
l’espace social structuré par la détention
des capitaux.
La définition de classes sociales provient
forcément d’une classification des pratiques
des agents mais ces pratiques sont elles-mêmes
porteuses de jugements classificatoires que
les agents font de ces mêmes pratiques et
de celles des autres agents.
Nous sommes ici proche du cœur du concept
d’habitus de Pierre Bourdieu. L’habitus
est cette disposition intériorisée à la
fois génératrice de pratiques ET système
de classement. Autrement dit, l’habitus
est le logiciel que j’ai intégré de part
ma socialisation qui fait que je me comporte
d’une certaine manière dans une certaine
situation mais aussi qui fait que je trouve
ce comportement et celui des autres appréciables
ou non.
L’habitus est une structure structurée
puisqu’il produit des comportements classables
et classés donc structurés et en même temps
une structure structurante qui classe les
pratiques.
C’est dans ce double mouvement de l’habitus
que l’espace des styles de vie se construit.
Si des individus ont des styles de vie très
proches, c’est parce que c’est le même
schème qui est actif pour la production et
la perception de ce styles de vie mais aussi
de celui des autres. Un autre schème d’action
produit inévitablement d’autres effets
et on voit ici que la co-existence dans l’espace
social est au moins basée sur la différenciation
si pas sur la confrontation des styles de
vie.
(Schéma) Le modèle théorique de Bourdieu
est assez limpide et élégant. Les conditions
d’existence d’un individu c’est-à-dire
la détention d’un volume et d’une structure
de capitaux produit une structure structurée
et structurante génératrice de pratiques
et de systèmes de valeurs conduisant à l’adoption
d’un certain style de vie distinctifs d’autres
styles de vie.
Les classements et les jugements de valeur
que nous opérons plus ou moins consciemment
à l’encontre d’autres individus sont
liés à notre habitus et se retrouvent dans
des qualifications et classification comme
“c’est distingué”, “ça fait bourge”,
“c’est un truc de beauf”, “c’est
vulgaire”, “c’est pour les barakis”,
“ce n’est vraiment pas pour moi”, “ce
n’est pas mon style”... que nous pouvons
faire de certaines pratiques. Bourdieu aimait
d’ailleurs répéter que le principe de
la distinction est le dégoût du goût des
autres rappelant par là le principe structurant
de l’habitus comme système de valeur.
Même si nous nous retrouvons dans une situation
totalement inédite. La structure structurée
et structurante de l’habitus nous conduit
à adopter un comportement et une perception
cohérente dans et pour notre classe et qui
est socialement compréhensible en dépit
de toute recherche intentionnelle de notre
part. Nous ne cherchons pas à être socialement
cohérent dans nos pratiques et pourtant nous
le sommes. Bourdieu dit que cet habitus produit,
par des retraductions contraintes aux champs
dans lesquels nous agissons, une harmonie
de pratique commune avec les autres membres
de notre classe. L’habitus permet des transpositions
systématiques en fonction des conditions
d’action qui font que l’on perçoit objectivement
des “airs de famille” entre les comportements
des membres d’une même classe sociale.
Pour bien comprendre ce qu’est l’habitus,
il faut donc s’intéresser à sa genèse.
L’habitus est forgé dans le quotidien de
nos vies, lui-même limité et conditionné
par la possession ou la non-possession de
certaines ressources qui font que nous intériorisons
certains réflexes et préférences. Par exemple,
les professeurs possèdent un assez bon volume
de capitaux mais avec un certain déséquilibre
dans leur structure. Ils possèdent plus de
capitaux culturels que de capitaux économiques.
De cette manière, il développe un certain
rapport ascétique au monde c’est-à-dire
qu’ils vont être très économes et privilégier
une consommation intellectuelle plutôt qu’une
consommation matérielle. En effet, ils préfèrent
“consommer” des oeuvres d’art dans les
musées et les expositions ce qui est une
pratique financièrement accessible autant
qu’intellectuellement exigeante que de se
lancer dans des collections personnelles d’oeuvres
d’art dont ils n’ont de toute façon pas
les moyens. Leur avidité culturelle est bornée
par leur ressources économiques limitées,
ils développent donc un habitus cohérent
avec cette condition qui sera à la base de
nouveaux comportements homogènes socialement.
Autre exemple, les classes populaires ont
un volume de capitaux faible. Celui-ci ne
permet pas d’engager du personnel de maison
et d’acheter des équipements ménagers
onéreux. Ils consacrent donc beaucoup de
temps aux tâches ménagères. Dès lors,
les personnes composant les classes populaires
développent un goût pour ce qui est fonctionnel
et pratique, “du facile à entretenir et
à nettoyer” à l’opposé des classes
dominantes qui privilégient l’esthétique
et le style à la fonction ou à l’usage.
Peu importe que tel utile ne soit pas pratique
du moment qu’il est beau.
Dans ces deux cas, cette disposition, à l’ascétisme
chez les professeurs, à l’usage chez les
classes populaires, restent actives dans d’autres
contextes et renforcent l’homogénéité
des styles de vie.
Il y a des conséquences philosophiques à
la théorie de Bourdieu. C’est une évidence
ou une mise en évidence sociale de l’amor
fati ou amour du destin tel que l’a formulé
Nietzsche. Les individus aiment ce qu’ils
sont et ce qu’ils ont autant que ce qu’ils
ont et sont ce qu’ils aiment car c’est
ce qu’ils peuvent être et ce qu’ils peuvent
avoir. Pour le dire plus simplement, on aime
ce que l’on a et on aime pas ce que l’on
ne peut avoir. On fait ce que l’on peut
et on rejette ce que l’on ne peut faire.
Pour pouvoir étudier en profondeur l’habitus
de chaque position sociale, Bourdieu rappelle
que l’on doit prendre en considération
différents éléments. En plus de la logique
propre de chacune des positions et de la distribution
voire de l’opposition des pratiques entre
les positions dans l’espace social, il faut
également envisager les contraintes intrinsèques
de chaque champ. L’alimentation ou le sport
en tant que champs sont porteurs de contraintes
sur lesquelles les schèmes de l’habitus
viennent décliner l’action de chaque agent.
Certains sports sont par exemple plus prédisposés
à être plus adoptés par certains groupes.
Le tennis ou le golf qui évitent les contacts
physiques et requièrent un certain style
sont intrinsèquement liés aux classes dominantes
dont l’habitus porte à privilégier le
style à la force purement physique. Cette
dernière plus conforme à l’habitus des
classes populaires est consacrée dans des
sports comme la boxe ou le culturisme. Cependant,
il ne faudrait pas en arriver à considérer
qu’un sport ou une pratique alimentaire
est par essence faite pour telle ou telle
classe sociale. Tout est question d’appropriation
et de retraduction. Le rugby peut être pris
comme exemple. Sport très physique, le rugby
est à l’origine un jeu populaire qui est
codifié et moralisé par les écoles d’élites
anglaises au XIXe siècle. Elles traduisent
une pratique de manière plus conforme à
l’habitus de classe en y intégrant des
éléments abstraits comme le fair-play et
une définition précise et minutieuse des
règles du jeu. De plus, certaines pratiques
peuvent, en leur sein, faire l’objet de
certaines singularités sociales. Le rugby
est ensuite devenu très populaire dans certaines
régions et touche aujourd’hui toutes les
couches sociales. Bourdieu remarque toutefois
que la pratique de ce sport n’est pas anodine
socialement et que des différenciations y
sont visibles. Les classes dominantes sont
plus attirées par le jeu des ¾. Ces joueurs
évitent les contacts par leur aisance et
leur style. Le jeu rude des avants qui vont
gratter les ballons par leur courage et leur
impact physique est plus conforme aux attentes
des classes populaires qui cherchent avant
tout à se défouler et à évacuer un excédent
d’influx par la pratique du sport.
Dans les chapitres suivants Bourdieu nous
offre un travail d'orfèvre en nous donnant
les clés de l’habitus de chaque classe
sociale.
Je consacrerai les prochains épisodes de
cette série à chacun de ces habitus de classe.
Cette vidéo est finie. N’oubliez pas de
vous abonner afin de ne pas rater la suite
de cette série consacrée à la distinction
de Pierre Bourdieu.
Je vous remercie de votre attention et je
vous dis à très bientôt sur La Sociothèque.